[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marieta Slomka guten Abend
bandenmäßige Korruption und Geldwäsche
das wirft die Brüsseler
Staatsanwaltschaft keiner geringeren als
seiner stellvertretenden
eu-parlamentspräsidentin vor sie und
weitere Verdächtige waren ja bereits am
Freitag festgenommen worden inzwischen
wurden sie einem Haftrichter vorgeführt
der heute für die Vizepräsidentin und
drei weitere Personen Haftbefehl
erteilte sie sitzen jetzt also im
Gefängnis in Untersuchungshaft heißt
also dass der Tatverdacht dringend ist
und Flucht oder Verdunklungsgefahr
angenommen wird für das EU-Parlament für
die EU insgesamt ist dieser Skandal ein
Donnerschlag Gunna Krüger berichtet aus
Brüssel
Wochenende in Brüssel und keine
Entspannung für das Europaparlament denn
der Skandal weitet sich aus um Marc
terabella Sozialdemokrat zuständig auch
für Beziehungen zur arabischen Halbinsel
früher war der Belgier ein schärfer
Kritiker der Wüsten WM zuletzt meinte er
nun sei es mal gut mit Katha Bashing
t natürlich ist die Situation in Katha
nicht perfekt da gibt's noch viel zu tun
aber das Land ist auf dem Weg der
Reformen daher sind diese einseitigen
negativen Äußerungen von heute für die
künftige Entwicklung der Rechte in Katha
schädlich
bei ihm durchsuchte gestern die Polizei
die Wohnung bei Eva kaieli mit der alles
losging entschied heute ein Richter sie
bleibt in Haft es war dieselbe Debatte
es ist derselbe Verdacht
als wir über die Katar Resolution
abgestimmt haben gab es viele Fragen
warum einige zum Beispiel bestimmte
Änderungsanträge einreichten es ist
völlig inakzeptabel das Abgeordnete für
ihre Position Geld nehmen
neues auch Zuri nach ZDF Recherchen
versuchte sie Einfluss auf die
wieserpolitik der EU gegenüber Katha zu
nehmen sie stimmte für Erleichterungen
in einem Ausschuss den sie nicht mal
angehörte was aufflog war das nur
oder wurde daraus Politik morgen ist
wieder Sitzungswoche das Parlament muss
reden über sich selbst
Einzelheiten zu diesem
abstimmungsvorfall können Sie übrigens
auf ZDF heute nachlesen
blicken wir jetzt nach China die
Kehrtwende die das chinesische Regime in
seiner corona-politik vollzieht ist ja
tatsächlich atemberaubend große Frage
ist wie wird sich das auswirken und das
betrifft ja nicht nur die Chinesen die
harte Politik bei denen so
gehandelsmetropolen wie Shanghai
abgeregelt wurden hatten ja weltweit
folgen nun könnte man auf den ersten
Blick meinen dass die neuen Lockerungen
für die Weltwirtschaft eine gute
Nachricht sind aber so eindeutig ist das
nicht unbedingt es wird davon abhängen
wie schwerwiegend die gesundheitlichen
Folgen sind und wie die Chinesen damit
umgehen Marion Steimer berichtet
alle Patienten in dieser
quarantäneunterkunft können jetzt nach
Hause gehen und sich dort isolieren
Quarantäne zu Hause drei Jahre lang war
das in Null kovet China undenkbar wer
einen positiven Test hatte musste in
eine staatliche Unterkunft
ein Grund für die 180 Grad Wende der
corona-politik die Führung hat die
Reißleine gezogen das Land hat so viele
Fälle wie nie es war nicht mehr möglich
jeden einzelnen und alle seine Kontakte
zu verfolgen und einzusperren trotz der
neuen Freiheiten sind Geschäfte und
Straßen leer in Peking oder in Wuhan wo
das Virus zum ersten Mal nachgewiesen
wurde seit fast 30 Jahren hat schuht
schon Ping hier sein Restaurant
es ist hart wirklich hart so kann man
keine Geschäfte mehr machen jetzt wo
alles wieder öffnet sind auch die
positiven Fälle draußen unterwegs
keiner kommt mehr ins Restaurant
denn die Leute haben Angst vor dem Virus
drei Jahre hat der Staat und seine
Propaganda mit dieser Angst die extremen
Maßnahmen durchgesetzt
die massiven Folgen dieser Maßnahmen für
die Wirtschaft das ist wohl der
Hauptgrund für die Lockerungen
zumal Staatschef sie den pingen mit den
wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten auch
seinen Einfluss in der weltausweiten
will
wenn das Vertrauen der internationalen
Wirtschaft in China als Drehscheibe für
Lieferungen zusammenbricht weil wir ja
für ja diese hochgradig politisierten
Entscheidungen und ständigen
Unterbrechungen der Lieferketten erleben
dann ist das wirklich gefährlich
beschleunigt wurde der eröffnungsplan
durch die Proteste gegen die strikten
corona-regeln die größten die China seit
Jahrzehnten erlebt hat wohl um den Druck
zu verringern wurden die Lockerungen
überstürzt vorgezogen ohne Vorbereitung
[Applaus]
das geschieht im Moment in einer Art
Panik und birgt das Risiko einer großen
Infektionswelle und einer signifikanten
Welle von Todesfällen insbesondere unter
der älteren Bevölkerung
denn gerade von den besonders
gefährdeten sind zu wenige geimpft die
abrupte Umstellung von Lockdown auf
durch solchungen könnte hunderttausende
das Leben kosten drei Jahre lang flossen
Staatsgelder in quarantäne-lager und
Massentests statt den Intensivbetten und
das Gesundheitssystem es ist ein
Wettlauf Impfkampagne gegen
Infektionswelle
im Europaparlament und ist der
Vorsitzende der China Delegation des
EU-Parlaments und antibi
interpretieren sie das
ich glaube ihre Korrespondentin hat
wirklich recht das ist ein Ausdruck von
Kopflosigkeit von Panik die Führung in
China hat sich da in einer Sackgasse
manövriert und
will jetzt die dramatischen ökonomischen
Konsequenzen vermeiden und muss dafür
möglicherweise mit einer gewissen
Wahrscheinlichkeit ein sehr hohen Preis
was die
Todesopfer betrifft bezahlen man muss
zum Beispiel wissen dass 90 Millionen
ältere Chinesen keinen ausreichenden
Impfschutz haben
nun gehören Sie zu denen die eine sehr
kritische Haltung gegenüber China
annehmen vor vielem annehmen vor vielem
warnen was anderen erst jetzt bewusst
geworden ist vor allem auch durch den
Ukraine Krieg was das bedeuten kann wenn
das dann plötzlich Sanktionen und
ähnliches gibt Stichwort Taiwan nun gibt
es die Forderung dass wir uns weniger
abhängig machen von den von der
chinesischen Wirtschaft Moment ist das
so dass die in deutschen eigentlich
abhängiger von China sind als umgekehrt
aber wie schwierig wird das wenn man
diese Abhängigkeiten denkt man das ist
unser größter Handelspartner
kein Konzern keine Volkswirtschaft kann
auf dem Absatz kehrt machen deswegen
sollten wir uns jetzt nicht in
irgendeiner hysterische Praxis stürzen
aber wir müssen mit Konsequenz die Lehre
ziehen aus der russischen Erfahrung dass
es für uns mit gefährlichen Folgen
verbunden ist wenn wir uns von einem
autoritären Regime abhängig machen und
ich China ist mächtiger als russland hat
mehr Mittel zur Verfügung Druck auf uns
auszuüben und wir sind auch von China
abhängiger als wir von Russland je waren
also müssen wir da Schritt für Schritt
Umsteuern interessant ist dass der
Mittelstand das zum erheblichen Teil
bereits tut bloß die ganz großen VW BASF
Siemens und so weiter die sind bis jetzt
da noch zögerlich aber ich glaube die
müssen auch Umdenken das sind auch
gerade Stichwort Mittelstand also es
gibt natürlich auch viele Unternehmen
die zum Beispiel Seltene Erden und
andere Rohstoffe verarbeiten die es fast
nur aus China gibt also Silikon zum
Beispiel Silizium die Unternehmen die
sowas verarbeiten Dialyse Schläuche und
ähnliches machen viele Mittelständler
die beziehen das zu 85% aus China also
muss ich wirklich nach anderen Ländern
eigentlich jetzt umgucken
ich glaube da gibt es im Moment eine
große Chance
tatsächlich haben Sie Recht die
Verarbeitungskapazitäten für viele
kritische Rohstoffe sind fast
monopolisiert in China obwohl es diese
Rohstoffe in vielen vielen Ländern gibt
ich nehme mal Namibia in Afrika als
Beispiel die haben Seltene Erden was sie
nicht haben ist eine
Verarbeitungskapazität es wäre also eine
interessante Idee wenn wir als Europäer
mit solchen Entwicklungsländern im
globalen Süden zusammenarbeiten um denen
denn Aufbau einer Verarbeitungskapazität
zu ermöglichen das hätte industriell für
die Vorteile und für uns wird es
bedeuten wir sind nicht mehr
ausschließlich auf China abhängig das EU
Parlament hat da ja auch Hebel seine
Handelspolitik anderen Ländern
afrikanischen Ländern gegenüber zu
verändern aber bisher haben wir da auch
sehr hohe Standards also es geht ja
nicht nur um Menschenrechte und
Nachhaltigkeit und Umweltschutz bei
Namibia gibt's da auch total Proteste
dass da dieser wasserstoffpark errichtet
wird
kommt man damit klar mit diesem
Zielkonflikten müssen wir uns da alle
etwas ehrlicher machen
ich glaube dass wir sehr genau über
unsere Prioritäten nachdenken müssen
Menschenrechte sind für mich sind für
uns im Europäischen Parlament immer eine
Priorität aber das heißt nicht dass wir
jetzt nur noch Handelsabkommen machen so
wie wir sie zum Beispiel mit Japan oder
mit Singapur gemacht haben wenn wir mit
Indien zum Beispiel zu zu Streich kommen
wollen und das Ziel ist bis Ende
nächsten Jahres dann Freihandelsabkommen
hinzukriegen dann werden wir da die
Prioritäten besser abschichten müssen
Stichwort Menschenrechte jetzt dieser
hochnot peinliche Korruptions Skandal
wir haben ja gerade darüber berichtet
dass sozusagen EU-Parlamentarier sich am
kaufen lassen und bei den Menschen
rechnen Katar nicht so genau hin zu
gucken wie schwer wird dieser wie groß
ist dieser Image schaden für das
Parlament in dem sie sitzen
also erst war ich sprachlos und jetzt
macht sich so Zorn und Bitterkeit breit
weil weil da eine ganze Institution in
verruft zu geraten droht durch diese
schamlose Haltung einzelner ich glaube
da hängt jetzt viel davon ab dass das
Parlament mit allem was es hat für eine
schonungslose Aufklärung sorgt
klarstellt dass egal ob Abgeordneter
Mitarbeiter für Korruption kein Platz
ist dass das Parlament die Regeln
verschärft was den Kontakt und den
lobbykontakt von Drittstaaten mit
Mitarbeitern oder mit Abgeordneten
betrifft und das dann die Justiz ihre
Pflicht tut bitte danke für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
und jetzt entfernen wir uns mal für
einen Moment vom Trübsal des irdischen
sozusagen
der Mut fasziniert die Menschheit
seitdem es sie gibt schon relativ früh
erkannte man also der Mensch wie der
Mond die Gezeiten unseres Planeten
beeinflusst aber es dauerte sehr lange
bis der Mensch sich diesen Himmelskörper
selbst ansah und dann am Ende auch
erstmals einen Fuß auf ihn setzte was in
ein paar Jahren ja wieder geschehen soll
heute kehrte die Kapsel der Mondmission
Artemis zur Erde zurück noch ohne
Menschen an Bord war sie rund vier
Wochen lang unterwegs und flog um den
Mond herum und von der erfolgreichen
Landung berichtet jetzt Claudia Bates
genau 50 Jahre nachdem zuletzt Menschen
auf dem Mond waren
landet die Raumkapsel Orion im Pazifik
der dramatischste Moment ihrer Mission
liegt gerade hinter ihr mit 40.000
Kilometern pro Stunde tritt Orion wieder
in die Erdatmosphäre ein ihr Hitzeschild
muss Temperaturen von rund 2800 Grad
standhalten das war der ultimative Test
denn beim nächsten Flug sollen in dieser
Kapsel ja Menschen sitzen
ich bin überwältigt heute ist ein
herausragender Tag
er ist historisch denn wir erforschen
jetzt wieder die Tiefen des Weltalls mit
einer neuen Generation
nach einem spektakulären Start mit der
neuen riesenrakete verbrachte Orion eine
Woche in einer Umlaufbahn des Mondes und
sandte Bilder nicht nur vom Erdtrabanten
sondern auch von der Erde selbst alle
Ziele hat das Raumschiff erreicht den
Vorbeiflug am Mond in nur rund 100 km
Entfernung das Einschwenken in dessen
Umlaufbahn der Mond fast greifbar mehr
als zwei Millionen Kilometer hat die
Kapsel bis zu ihrer Rückkehr zur Erde
zurückgelegt
das ist wirklich der Beginn einer neuen
Ära in der astronautischen Raumfahrt in
der Entdeckung des Weltraums wir
schaffen es zum ersten Mal zusammen als
Menschheit nicht nur eine Nation zum
Mond zu fliegen nicht nur um eine Flagge
aufzustellen sondern aus wichtigem
wissenschaftlichen Gründen die ja
letztendlich wichtig sind für den Erhalt
unserer eigenen Spezies auch die
europäische Weltraumorganisation ist an
der artemismission beteiligt hier auf
der kanarischen Insel Lanzarote proben
sie bereits alexander Gerst ist einer
der aussichtsreichsten Kandidaten für
den Flug zum Mond hier nimmt er
Gesteinsproben und bereitet sich auch
mental vor auf einen Ausflug in einem
Mondlandschaft die Landung der Artemis
heute hat in der Mission einen großen
Schritt näher gebracht
dies ist ein ganz entscheidender Tag er
markiert eine neue Technologie und eine
ganz neue Art von Astronauten
wir sind Abenteurer wir sind Entdecker
wir wollen immer Grenzen überwinden und
das heißt jetzt den Himmel weiter zu
erforschen
nun wird die Mission ausgewertet den
Blick fest darauf gerichtet wie der
Menschen auf den Mond zu bringen und
schließlich auf den Mars
online finden Sie dazu auch noch eine
umfängliche 3D-Grafiken unserer ZDF
heute App oder auf der Webseite können
Sie sich selbst auf den Weg ins All
machen und sich zum Mond klicken und
zoomen und interaktiv die neue
Raumstation erkunden und so noch mehr
erfahren über die Mondmission Artemis
und ihr großes Fernziel den Menschen auf
dem Mars zu bringen
und jetzt geht es mit den Nachrichten
bei dir weiter Heinz zunächst mit der
Lage in der Ukraine Ziel der russischen
Angriffe in der Ukraine war zuletzt
verstärkt auch die Hafenstadt Odessa
dort wurde die Energieinfrastruktur so
stark getroffen dass die Stadt
vermutlich für Wochen weitgehend von der
Stromversorgung abgeschnitten sein wird
laut Präsident selensky sind in der
Region mehr als 1,5 Millionen Menschen
betroffen denn wir wohnen wurde
empfohlen die Stadt vorübergehend zu
verlassen im Osten der Ukraine ist der
wichtige Verkehrsknotenpunkt bachmut von
russischem Beschuss fast vollständig
zerstört worden
die ukrainische Armee reagierte mit
Raketenangriffen in dann jetzt und
Melitopol
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
in der Diskussion über das Vorgehen in
der Corona Bekämpfung betont dass die
relativ strengen Regeln in Deutschland
auch etwas gebracht hätten im Interview
mit der ZDF-Sendung Berlin direkt sagte
Lauterbach man habe im Vergleich zu
anderen europäischen Ländern eine
niedrigere Sterblichkeit gehabt
Lauterbach appellierte weiterhin
vorsichtig zu sein im nächsten Jahr
erwartet er eine deutliche Entlastung
nach der umfangreichen Razzia im
Reichsbürger Milieu plant in den
Ministerin Felser eine Verschärfung des
Waffenrechts mehr als 1.000 sogenannten
reichsbürgern habe man die
Waffenerlaubnis schon entzogen so Fräse
in der Bild am Sonntag die Ministerin
warnte vor einer wachsenden Gefahr durch
die Szene
der leichtere Zugang zum
Kurzarbeitergeld soll wegen der
Energiekrise bis Ende Juni verlängert
werden Bundesarbeitsminister Heil sagte
dem redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
Kurzarbeit sei in den vergangenen
Monaten eine stabile brücke über ein
tiefes wirtschaftliches Tal gewesen
diese Brücke trage auch weiterhin die
Sonderregelung waren in der
corona-pandemie beschlossen und mehrmals
verlängert worden zuletzt bis Ende
dieses Jahres
zwei Rettungsschiffe mit mehr als 500
Migranten an Bord haben süditalienische
Häfen erreicht die humanity one durfte
in Bari anlegen und die geobarens in
Salerno diese Erlaubnis ändere aber
nichts an der Haltung der Regierung
bezüglich
illegaler Migration ist es aus Rom
im Ahrtal gibt es eine eigene
Zeitrechnung vor und nach dem Juli 2021
als die Flut kam fast anderthalb Jahre
ist das jetzt her eine Katastrophe wie
man sie sich dort nicht hat vorstellen
können 134 Menschen verloren ihr Leben
zwei werden noch immer vermisst die
Zerstörungen sind so gewaltig dass einem
immer wieder die Luft wegbleibt wenn man
solche Bilder sieht
für die sende Reihe zdfin sind unsere
Reporterin Marion Geiger und Kameramann
Christoph Timm vier Wochen lang im
Ahrtal unterwegs und fragen wie ist den
Überlebenden heute geht und wieder
Wiederaufbau voran kommt
parthena an meiner tides ist glücklich
und wütend zugleich einerseits hat sie
es geschafft ihr Restaurant in Ahrweiler
ist wieder geöffnet der Familienbetrieb
war in der Flut letztes Jahr schwer
zerstört worden die Familie nicht
versichert mit freiwilligen Helfern
haben sie monatelang geschuftet um den
Betrieb wieder aufzubauen die
Gastronomin bekam private Spenden auf
staatliche Hilfe aber wartet sie immer
noch ich bin wütend ich bin enttäuscht
ich verliere einfach das Vertrauen
das Geld für den Wiederaufbau kam vor
allem von Amanatidis Eltern deren
Ersparnissen für die Rente bis zu 80%
ihrer kosten könnte der staatliche
fluthilfe vor erstatten doch die Sache
mit dem Antrag zieht sich hier noch ein
Gutachten da noch ein Schreiben da noch
dies da das bist du diese ganzen Sachen
alleine schon mal zusammen hast ist
schon so viel Zeit wieder in Land
gelaufen dass man einfach auch die
Hoffnung verliert wenn man nicht weiß
wann geht's denn jetzt vorwärts und es
ist alles jetzt schon komplett abgegeben
seit sechs Monaten und es ist noch keine
Rückmeldung
die Familie ist froh mit dem Restaurant
wieder selbst Geld zu verdienen soweit
sind längst nicht alle in der Altstadt
von Ahrweiler einen Nebeneinander von
saniert und kaputt immerhin es ist
wieder Weihnachtsmarkt Ahrweiler wieder
weihnachtlich zu sehen das ist wirklich
unglaublich toll und gibt mir und auch
allen anderen hier wirklich viel Kraft
zwischen Glühwein und gebrannten Mandeln
bleibt die Flut Thema Nummer 1
Handwerker ist schwierig irgendwo es
gibt zu wenige davon ne und ja man ist
ständig ständiges warten irgendwo
gewohnt viele meckern ja auch nur ist
auch in vielen Sachen richtig aber bei
uns funktioniert diese Hilfe die kommen
sollte angeblich schnell und
unbürokratisch war überhaupt nicht der
Fall hat einfach viel zu lange gedauert
auch die Kommunen kämpfen mit der
Bürokratie allein in Bad
Neuenahr-Ahrweiler sind 1400 Anträge
nötig um die zerstörte Infrastruktur
wieder aufzubauen noch keine 100 sind
gestellt der Knackpunkt ist das Personal
die Landesregierung macht nun
sonderzuladen möglich damit überhaupt
Fachkräfte ins Flutgebiet kommen wir
bekommen weder technisches Personal noch
Verwaltungspersonal gut ausgebildet und
zwar langfristig
Abordnungen für zwei Monate helfen uns
nicht die sind gerade eingearbeitet dann
müssen sie wieder gehen
16 Monate nach der Flut sind die
Menschen im Ahrtal ernüchtert bis die
Flutschäden behoben sind das Wissen hier
alle wird es noch etliche Zeit dauern
und jetzt noch mal Heinz Wolf mit
anderen Themen seit heute geht bei der
Deutschen Bahn ein neuer Fahrplan
gleichzeitig gibt es Preissteigerungen
um durchschnittlich knapp fünf Prozent
dafür sollen neue schnellere
Verbindungen und eine höhere Zug Taktung
des Bahnnetz optimieren zusätzlich wird
es im Fernverkehr auf einigen Strecken
mehr Sitzplätze geben reisende müssen
aber auch 2023 mit Sperrungen und
Umleitungen wegen zahlreicher
Großbaustellen rechnen
zum Wintersport bester Deutscher
Skispringer beim Weltcup in
Titisee-Neustadt war Karl Geiger mit
Platz 5 Tagessieger wurde der Pole David
copatzki beste deutsche Springerin dort
war Katharina Althaus und sie war auch
überhaupt die beste heute im Wettbewerb
dank eine Sprungs auf 137 Meter im
zweiten Durchgang gewann sie vor der
Norwegerin sehe obset
beim rodelweltcup im kanadischen Wissler
lief es nach dem Sieg von Felix Loch
gestern heute weiter erfolgreich für die
deutsche Mannschaft bei den
Doppelsitzern gewann das Duo Toni
eckertzer Benecken vor ihren
Teamkollegen Tobias wendel Tobias alt
und zudem markierte Deutschland auch die
beste Zeit im Staffelwettbewerb
all you can eat das restaurantprinzip
kennt jeder pay what you can ist
seltener zu allem was du kannst es gibt
immer wieder mal Restaurants die das
ausprobieren allerdings müssen sich die
Betreiber dann schon sehr auf die Moral
ihrer Gäste verlassen können meist geht
es dabei auch eher darum überhaupt
erstmal Werbung für sein Lokal zu machen
und Gäste anzuziehen
letzteres ist auch ein Motiv bei der
Initiative pay what you can im deutschen
Kulturbetrieb bei dieser und anderen
neuen Ideen geht es nicht nur um den
sozialen Aspekt Menschen die in diesem
Winter schwer sparen müssen den Gang ins
Theater oder Konzert leichter zu machen
sondern es geht auch darum die
corona-geschädigten Häuser wieder voll
zu bekommen
endlich wieder volle Häuser ausverkaufte
Konzerte glückliche Schauspieler und ein
begeistertes Publikum in Hagen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist dieses kleine
Wunder wahr geworden musicalhelden wie
Amy Winehouse oder David Bowie für wenig
Geld das Theater Hagen präsentiert im
dritten krisenwender das 9 Euro Ticket
für alle
wenn wir im September ungefähr 30-35%
ausgelastet waren dann waren wir
plötzlich im Oktober eben 70 80 90%
ausgelastet jetzt sind viele
Vorstellungen ausverkauft neue Wege
gehen neue eintrittsmodelle testen bloß
nicht den Kopf in den Sand stecken ist
das Motto der Thüringer Bach Wochen pay
what you can das Prinzip das Publikum
entscheidet an der Kasse was jede oder
jeder zahlen kann oder will
es geht da nicht um einen Ausverkauf der
Kultur es geht nicht darum dass wir
sagen bezahlt doch was ihr wollt sondern
eben wirklich darum zu sagen was ihr
könnt so dass jeder auch derjenige der
vielleicht gerade mit den Heizkosten ein
Problem bekommt trotzdem offene Türen
vorfindet
an diesem Abend steht in Erfurt ein
renaissance-konzert auf dem Programm
Grendel Laura ein belgisches
spitzenensemble 25 € ist der Richtpreis
doch wer zahlt wie viel 1 € ist das
Minimum erste Überraschung der Andrang
ist groß die zweite die meisten halten
sich an die Vorgabe und alle sind
begeistert
Kultur haben wir ja Nachholbedarf
irgendwo ne und deswegen sind wir sehr
dankbar dafür dass es sowas gibt ich
habe 10 Euro ausgegeben also nicht ganz
so viel ich kenne die Band nicht ja ich
finde es toll also dann das alle die
interessiert sind kommen können und da
wenn ich kann dann zahle ich einfach
mehr
selbst die Hauptstadt hat mitgemacht das
Konzerthaus am Gendarmen nennt ihr neues
bezahlen Modell erlebnis-ticket
Richtwert hier 35 €, das Berliner Motto
erst erleben dann bezahlen
ich glaube dass dieses erlebnis-ticket
einfach die Hemmschwelle noch weiter
runter senkt und wir so die Chance haben
nachhaltig eben auch ein Publikum zu
gewinnen
[Musik]
die Goldberg Variationen auch in Berlin
ist das erlebnis-ticket ein voller
Erfolg acht Konzerte mit 95% Auslastung
fast die Hälfte zahlte beim ersten
Testlauf den empfohlenen Richtpreis
manche sogar deutlich mehr über
anschlussprojekte wird nachgedacht
pay what you can Kultur für alle
bezahlbar und erschwinglich ein Modell
für die Zukunft in Hagen ist das Theater
wieder eine erste Adresse doch das 9 €
Ticket gilt nur noch bis Silvester
und jetzt schauen wir noch kurz nach
vorne auf die nächste Woche in sehr mit
unserem Ausblick
[Musik]
wenn sich bereits am Montag zwei
Ausschüsse des Bundestags mit der
großrazieher gegen Reichsbürger
beschäftigen unterstreicht das den Ernst
der Lage denn das mutmaßliche
Terrornetzwerk hat der offenbar Pläne
den Deutschen Bundestag anzugreifen
außerdem soll es um Vorabinfos an Medien
zu der Razzia gehen
wenn sich am Donnerstag in Brüssel die
Regierungschefs der EU zu einem
eintägigen Gipfeltreffen geht es um Geld
viel Geld zwei Zahlungen an Ungarn
zusammen mehr als 13 Milliarden Euro die
aber an bestimmte Reformen gebunden sind
und ein 18 Milliarden EU Hilfspaket für
die Ukraine das Ungarn blockiert es
könnte eine lange Nacht werden
wenn am Samstag vor Wilhelmshaven das
erste schwimmende Terminal für den
Import von Flüssiggas in Betrieb geht
hat die Bundesregierung im Eiltempo eine
völlig neue Infrastruktur auf den Weg
gebracht es geht um Unabhängigkeit von
Russland und Wege aus der Energiekrise
das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium rechnet
damit dass die Anlage knapp 4% des
deutschen Jahres Gas Bedarfs abdecken
könnte
wenn am Sonntag das letzte Sonnenlicht
versiegt und das Rosen tausende Fans den
Abend durchdringt beginnt im lucael
Stadion in Katar das letzte Spiel dieser
etwas anderen WM
und jetzt die Wetteraussichten zum Start
in die neue Woche morgen schneit es in
Brandenburg und in Sachsen sonst ist es
meist trocken die Sonne zeigt sich immer
häufiger im Osten wird ein böiger Wind
und die Temperatur erreicht -4 bis 3
Grad die kommenden Tage bringen dem
Süden zeitweise Schnee im Norden ist es
freundlicher teils mit längeren
Sonnenschein überall bleibt es kalt mehr
als minus vier bis plus 2 Grad werden es
nicht
das was im heute journal morgen Abend
freuen sich hier Christian Sievers in
Hanna Zimmermann auf sie und um 0:30 Uhr
gibt es die nächste heute Express auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]